die sommerpressekonferenz des
bundeskanzlers war olaf scholz an der
einen oder anderen stelle mal wieder
etwas ausweichen da geantwortet hat gab
es auch kritik für den auftritt gestern
zum beispiel von der afd und mit der afg
in person mit tino keller dem
fraktionsvorsitzenden und bundessprecher
will ich jetzt sprechen über die
sommerpressekonferenz des kanzlers hallo
nach weißwasser in sachsen hallo herr
krupp aller
guten morgen hallo ich grüße sie herr
pofalla der bundeskanzler glaubt nicht
dass es künftig soziale unruhen im land
geben könnte die entlastung also hat er
sich dann zuversichtlich optimistisch
gezeigt gestern die die bundesregierung
auf den weg gebracht hat die säulen
können würden was denken sie darüber
ja insgesamt hat mich schon diese
schönfärberei gestern bei dieser
sogenannten sommerpressekonferenz
fassungslos zurück gelassen also hier
werden wirklich probleme die
mittlerweile die bürger betreffen wenn
ich jetzt zum beispiel an die haushalte
mit an den haushalten denke die mit
mehrkosten von 3000 euro zu rechnen
haben was die gasanlage angegriffen habe
ich also wir sind kosten bereits die auf
die bürger zukommen wo die entlastung
eben noch nicht greifen wird und er hier
wird ein entlastungspaket für 23
vorgeschlagen also viel zu spät also ich
denke dass greift alles nicht weit genug
und das macht schönes stück weit ratlos
weil sie sagen das greift nicht weit
genug jetzt nehmen wir einfach den fall
an die afd wäre in
regierungsverantwortung der kanzler
diese gruppe h was würde denn anders
machen
wir müssen ja erst mal beleuchten was
sind eigentlich die ursachen für die
inflation steigerung für die
energiepreise also das sind ja aktuell
die dinge die wir mal besprechen müssen
und dazu zählt der wirtschaftskrieg
angefochten von herrn haben die
wirtschaftssanktionen gegen russland die
natürlich da die ursache dafür sehen die
müssen aufgehoben werden nord stream
zwei muss geöffnet werden damit wir
wieder günstiges gas aus russland
bekommen und damit wiederum die
haushalte sofort entlastet werden und
auch unsere vorschläge dass zum beispiel
die mehrwertsteuer auf
grundnahrungsmittel gesenkt wird das zum
beispiel auch die energie steuer
abgeschafft ausgesetzt oder gesenkt wird
damit würde man sofort die
geringverdiener die mittelschicht
entlasten und in erst 23 was viel zu
spät käme jetzt hat ihre partei
mitstreiterin als zweite gestern dem
kanzler ja vorgeworfen gänzlich untätig
zu sein ich werde das bei ihnen jetzt
auch so ein bisschen raus nicht von der
hand weisen lässt sich ja aber doch dass
das eine oder andere auch auf den weg
gebracht wurde von der bundesregierung
das auch so sehen dass experten gewirkt
hat wie der tank rabatt zum beispiel
ist es nicht unfair vor dem hintergrund
dem kanzler vorzuwerfen daher gänzlich
untätig zu sein
wissen sie der regierung versucht mit
entlastungs paketen probleme zu lösen
die sie ja selbst geschaffen hat und wie
ich schon gesagt habe wir auch alles
weiter gesagt hat greifen natürlich
diese entlastungen überhaupt nicht weit
genug und werden die bürger auch nicht
in lassen vor allem familien und rentner
werden hier weiterhin zur kasse gebeten
wie gesagt es wird ein heißer herbst
wird ein kalter winter für viele werden
wenn sie sich nämlich die
heizkostenabrechnungen nicht mehr
leisten können wenn stadtwerke
wahrscheinlich auch die rechnungen nicht
mehr bezahlt bekommen und deswegen gibt
es ja auch die 1000 euro die im prinzip
diese gas um lage sein soll um ihn
wirklich in finanzielle not geratene
unternehmen zu retten was habe ich hier
veranstaltet also hauptverursacher ist
wie gesagt der wirtschaftskrieg von
hanna weg initiiert von herrn lindner
von herrn scholz das muss wirklich
gesagt werde und das muss aber vor allen
dingen das kann man ändern indem man
diese wirtschaftssanktionen sofort
beendet gegen russland in dem man wieder
günstig gas kauft und nicht auf teure
alternativen zurückgreifen muss aus den
usa herr kopp aller ich habe ihn
abschließend noch ein zitat mitgebracht
je schlechter ist deutschland geht desto
besser für die afg das hat christian
lüth gesagt ex fraktionssprecher der afd
mit der bitte um eine kurze antwort
stehen damit goldene zeiten jetzt ins
haus für die afd
wissen sie für die ard ist es wichtig
dass es deutschland gut geht wir sind
die alternative für deutschland wir
haben alternative konzepte die ich ihnen
grad genannt das ist für uns wichtig
dass insgesamt deutschland wieder gut
ist dass wir als souveräner staat
endlich wieder in erscheinung treten und
das tun wir eben nicht wir lassen uns
hier von fremden mächten wirklich
erklären was wir zu tun und zu lassen
haben nicht im interesse deutschlands
wir wollen für unsere bürger politik
machen das ist das ziel auf die und
dafür macht treten wir auch ein als die
einzig wahrnehmbare opposition sagte
pofalla der fraktionsvorsitzende der afg
und bundessprecher herzlichen für das
gespräch
sehr gerne